collegiality and focus on bipartisanship
in the 1990s four percent of the world's
population used the internet
today that number is nearly 60 the
internet is a tool with incredible
opportunities for expanding freedom and
democracy in america
and around the world but we need to
confront the reality that multinational
corporations are sabotaging americans
access to information
and advancing authoritarian regime's
efforts to manipulate the internet
for oppression when the internet was
first developed its potential as a
bastion of democracy was easily
recognized president reagan famously
said
technology will make it increasingly
difficult for the state to control the
information
its people receive the goliath of
totalitarianism will be brought down
by the david of the microchip we are now
seeing big tech making content related
decisions for people around the world
including here in the united states what
content is available to a free
citizenry is driven and shaped by the
political agendas of these tech
corporations
not consumer preferences we're not
seeing a systemic problem with people
shutting themselves out of the public
discourse as critics feared
instead the tech tightens censoring
material they disagree with
and they're able to do this because they
have achieved monopoly status in the
market
their monopoly has given them the power
to police the marketplace of ideas
and dictate what consumers can see this
problem is exacerbated by small and
medium
market news sources disappearing because
monopolies are squeezing them out of the
market
companies like google and facebook have
decimated small and media market news
sources by cutting their ad revenues in
2010
google publicly disclosed how much of
the ad revenue they shared with
publishers at the time
publishers were earning almost 70
percent of the revenue from content ads
which are the ads you see on a
publisher's website in 2020 the
association of national advertisers
estimated
that publishers are now only taking home
between 30 and 40
of the ad revenue that's a huge decrease
and we have seen the adverse effects of
that change
since 2004 the united states has lost
approximately 2 100 newspapers which
accounts for a quarter of the nation's
total
in 2004 there were almost 9 000
newspapers
but by the end of 2019 that number
dropped to 6 700.
more than 200 of the nation's 3143
counties and parishes no longer have a
local paper
and the newsrooms that are closing are
mostly in small rural communities
similarly local radio and tv stations
are also disappearing at an alarming
rate
study after study shows that americans
are more trusting of local news outlets
and local reporters and with good reason
there is more diversity of viewpoint in
the small and medium market outlets
that diversity allows space for more
voices and it benefits our democracy
my concerns about the decline in local
news outlets are not based on some
nostalgia for a former era
the robust exchange of ideas has always
been important in this country but it is
now essential as conservatives seek to
battle cancel culture and maintain a
voice in the public square
many of my colleagues advocate doing
nothing in this area because we should
just let the market work
from this perspective newspapers and
local tv and radio stations dying
is just the result of competition in a
healthy marketplace
they lean on the idea of creative
destruction and darwinian competition
i value the market economic freedom and
capitalism but i also value
freedom of speech and freedom of the
press i want to see these bedrock
american values preserved for future
generations
we are seeing the failures of antitrust
policy at work with big tech
big tech not only controls the news
market because it controls the digital
advertising market
it also exercises gatekeeper control
over speech
all americans should be concerned we are
just starting to see the results of
tech titan control over the news and how
it does not and it does not bode well
for future generations
congress sat idly by as these platforms
became monopolies
we cannot sit by and let them become the
public square too
we cannot let them become the arbiters
of truth and the wielders of
government-like power these companies
track and seek to run our lives
through their technologies and
algorithms big tech companies have
become digital kings and they represent
precisely the kind of political power
the antitrust laws are designed to
tackle
this bill is a step in the right
direction to dethroning those digital
kings it will give publishers and
broadcasters
a four-year exemption from the ai trust
laws so they can more effectively
bargain with google and facebook
it is not a subsidy for outlets but
rather a leveling of the
of the playing field in favor of
democracy and free expression
mr chairman i also want to make sure
that through this legislation
we are not creating unintended
consequences that will end up harming
those we seek to help
for example you want to make sure that
news outlets involved in negotiations
are not incentivized to harm the
interests
of competitor news groups not at the
table likewise we want to ensure that
google is not harming those it hasn't
negotiated with by burying them several
pages back in search results
i am pleased that this bill gives small
town outlets like the greeley tribune
and the fort morgan times
and conservative outlets like breitbart
and the federalists a chance to
negotiate together
and claw back some of their hard-earned
advertising dollars from google and
facebook
advertising dollars are the lifeblood of
these outlets earned through hard work
and dedicated reporting mr chair i
appreciate the opportunity to work
together and i yield back
i thank the gentleman for yielding black
back i now recognize the ranking member
of the full committee the gentleman from
ohio
mr jordan for his opening statement
thank you mr chairman um
i want to thank our witnesses for being
here today and i'm going to do something
i don't think i've ever done before in
an opening statement i'm going to read
from a couple of the
individuals mr travis mr greenwald had i
read their their full statements last
night very compelling testament i'm
going to read from
part of those because i think they
capture what what the situation truly is
let me start with mr travis's written
testament he says this algorithm
algorithms are designed by humans and
the results are monitored facebook can
make any site
soar in popularity or crush their
traffic and they can do it in an instant
this is the power of big tech writ large
we are living in a new gilded age where
tech billionaires
may be soon to be trillionaires have
more power than any elected official in
the land facebook's mark zuckerberg
twitter jack dorsey apple's tim cook
alphabet sundar pachai and amazon's jeff
bezos have more power today than andrew
carney jp morgan john d rockefeller and
henry ford
ever did in the earliest days of the
20th century
these modern day tech monopolists can
pick presidential election winners
control our national debates decide
whose voice is heard whose voice is not
heard
the supreme court no longer decides what
the law of the first amendment is in
this great country
these tech executives do in practice big
tech controls the country and they
control the country by deciding
what we see well said mr travis i mean
if this doesn't underscore why we need
to remove the liability protection in
section 230 i don't know what does
mr greenwald make the same points in his
written testimony and then he says this
about the specific question
at hand at this committee hearing today
he says how congress sets out to address
silicon valley's immense and
undemocratic power
is a complicated question well it is
posing complex challenges
the proposal to vest media companies
with an anti-trust exemption
in order to allow them to negotiate as a
consortium or cartel
seeks to rectify a real and serious
problem
very true but this is important but
empowering large media companies could
easily
end up creating more problems than it
solves
it goes on to say this further
empowering this already powerful media
industry
which has demonstrated will use its
force to silence competitors under the
guise of
quality control runs the real risk of
transferring the abusive monopoly power
from silicon valley
to corporate media companies this last
clause is important
or even worse encouraging some sort of
de facto merger
in which these two industries pool their
power to the mutual benefit of each
we already saw that happen we saw it
last in last fall's election
both mr travis and mr greenwald cite
this in their written testimony last
fall when big media teamed up with big
tech to make sure the american people
didn't hear about the hunter biden story
in the weeks leading up to a
presidential election so we've already
seen him team
up against we the people and now we have
legislation
that's going to give big media this
consortium and cartel power
the same time we're looking to use any
trust law to deal with big tech
we're going to give an anti-trust
exemption to big media
maybe that's the right course but i
gotta i got real questions about that
whether we should move in that direction
so i look forward to hearing from our
witnesses i want to thank him again for
coming
particularly mr travis who travels here
in person i appreciate
his good work and we look forward to a
chance to hear from
each of our witnesses mr chairman with
that i yield back
the gentleman yields back it's now my
pleasure to introduce today's witnesses
our first witness is david chavern the
president and ceo
of the news media alliance where he has
served since 2015.
mr javert spent 10 years at the united
states chamber of commerce
in a number of executive roles including
executive vice president chief operating
officer
and chief of staff he's a member of the
board of director of transamerica
insurance
and serves on the board of trustees at
the university of pittsburgh
mr chavern received his bachelor of arts
degree from the university of pittsburgh
his mba from georgetown university and
his jd from villanova university school
of law
i would now like to recognize my
distinguished colleague and the vice
chair
of this subcommittee miss jayapal to
introduce our second
witness and i know she does so with
incredible pride
miss john paul you're recognized thank
you so much mr chairman and thank you
for this opportunity to welcome mr brad
smith the president of microsoft and a
fellow washingtonian
who has done a tremendous amount for our
region our state and indeed our country
mr smith is one of the leading global
figures in the technology industry today
and he's testified several times before
the united states congress and other
governments
on policy issues he joined microsoft in
1993
spending three years leading the legal
and corporate affairs team
in europe in 2002 he was named
microsoft's general counsel
and led the company's work to resolve
anti-trust controversies with
governments around the world
and companies across the tech sector i
believe that's given him a very unique
and valuable perspective on
issues of tech and anti-trust and the
responsibility of the tech industry to
work with government
on smart regulation that protects
competition innovation and democracy
and mr chairman i actually believe that
that experience is very much part of the
reason that microsoft played
such a productive role in australia most
recently and i know we're going to hear
about that more today
before joining microsoft mr smith worked
as an associate and then
partner at the law firm covington in
burling he earned his ba from princeton
university has jd from columbia
university law school and studied
international law and economics
at the graduate institute in geneva
switzerland mr smith i thank you
for joining us but also for the
tremendous tremendous work you do
um in our state and in our country i
look forward to your testimony today
i thank the general lady and i also want
to thank mr smith for his
assistance during the course of our
investigation he provided a very
valuable briefing to members of the
subcommittee
during the course of our 16-month
investigation and again thank you for
that
our third witness is jonathan schloss
who is the president of the news guild
communications workers
of america a union that represents more
than 20 000 journalists
and media workers across the united
states and canada before being elected
president of cwa
mr schloss was a graphics and data
journalist at the los angeles times
where he led their unionization efforts
in 2018.
this marked the first time in the
paper's 135-year history
that the newsroom had been organized mr
sussex has also served as the online
editor at the northwest arkansas
democrat
gazette and as a weekend host for our
kuaf
national public radio affiliate based in
fayetteville arkansas
he is also an adjunct professor at the
usc
annenberg school of communications and
journalism mr schloss received his
bachelor's degree from the university of
arkansas
our fourth witness emily barr is
president and ceo of graham media group
as ceo ms barr has overseen seven local
media hubs
all top 70 markets since 2012.
under her leadership grand media group
was named the 2016
station group of the year by
broadcasting cable magazine
this bar has spent more than four
decades leading and working in broadcast
newsrooms
before joining gmg ms barr served as
president
and general manager at abc 7 chicago
from 1997 through 2012
and wtvd-tv and abc owned
stationed in raleigh from 1994 to 1997.
currently she serves on the boards of
both the associated press and the
television bureau of advertising
is the chairman for television for the
national association of broadcasters
ms barr was most recently named 2020's
broadcaster of the year
by broadcasting in cable this bar
received her ba from carlton college
and his her master's degree from george
washington university
our fifth witness glenn greenwald is a
journalist and constitutional lawyer
in 2014 mr greenwald co-founded first
look media
first look media's the intercept an
online publication where he served as an
editor
he left the publication in 2020 and
currently operates a popular sub stack
newsletter
prior to joining the intercept mr
greenwald's work was featured by both
the guardian and salon
he's received a number of awards for his
reporting including the park center iaf
stone award for independent journalism
in 2018 and the 2010 online journalism
award
for his coverage of the abusive
detention conditions of chelsea manning
the nsa reporting he led for the
guardian was awarded the 2014 pulitzer
prize
for public service he's written four new
york times bestsellers including no
place to hide
edward snowden the nsa and the u.s
surveillance state
prior to his writing career mr greenwald
is an active litigator
specializing in civil rights and first
amendment cases mr greenwald received
his bachelor's degree from george
washington university
and his jd from the new york university
school of law
today's last witness clay travis is the
founder of outkick
the coverage a popular sports and
entertainment website
he's also the host of outkick the
coverage on fox sports radio
the out kick the show live stream and
wins and losses podcast on iheartradio
mr travis has also had a number of books
including on rocky top
a front row seat to the end of an era
and republican by
republicans buy sneakers two how the
left is ruining sports with politics
before his media career mr travis was a
lawyer working in the us virgin islands
and tennessee with a popular personal
blog
he ended his legal career in 2006 to
focus full-time
on writing and entertainment he's also
served as a writer and editor at
deadspin as well as a national columnist
at fan house
mr travis received his bachelor's degree
from george washington university
and his jd from vernerville law school
we welcome all of our distinguished
witnesses and we thank you for your
participation in today's hearing
i will begin by swearing in our
witnesses i ask our witnesses testifying
in person to rise
and i ask our witnesses testifying
remotely to turn on their audio
and make sure that we can see your face
and your raised right hand
while i administer the oath do you swear
or affirm under penalty of perjury that
the testimony you are about to give is
true and correct
to the best of your knowledge
information and beliefs so help you god
i do thank you at the record show the
witnesses answered in the affirmative
thank you you may be
seated uh please note again to all the
witnesses that your written statements
will be entered into the record in their
entirety
and accordingly i ask that you summarize
your testimony in five minutes
to help stay to help you stay within
that time frame there's a timing light
in webex
when light switches from green to yellow
you have one minute to conclude
when the light turns red it signals that
your five minutes have expired
i'll begin now by recording mr shaburn
for five minutes
thank you chairman sistelini ranking
member buck and members of the
subcommittee thank you for inviting me
to participate in today's hearing
my name is david chavern and i'm the
president and ceo of the news media
alliance a non-profit trade association
representing over 2 000 news
organizations across the united states
our members range from small local
newspapers to some of the largest news
organizations in the world
the news media is and always has been an
essential part of our democracy
we are after all the only business
mentioned in the first amendment
the core function of news media is to
provide robust coverage of global
national and local issues from covet
1919 pandemic to corruption by state
officials
their ability to fulfill that role
however is under threat
and congress's help is needed to combat
that threat
though journalists commitment to public
interest has remained the same the way
that readers consume news content and
advertisers communicate with those
consumers
has changed dramatically over the years
and as the world has moved online
so has our industry our innovations have
allowed news media to provide real-time
updates on rapidly unfolding stories
such as catastrophic weather events and
public health crisis
local journalism has also acted as a
clear antidote to the scourge of
misinformation
impacting communities across the country
fundamentally our readership
is at its highest levels ever but while
news organizations continue to invest
heavily in generating critically
valuable reporting
a few dominant companies in the digital
ecosystem ensure that little value is
returned to publishers
the government cannot regulate the news
business under the first amendment but
there are now two companies in
particular google and facebook
that clearly do regulate us their
algorithms determine when
and if news is seen in search results
and news feeds
they determine how news is presented to
readers they collect
and control data about our news
audiences
and they control the systems and markets
around digital advertising these
challenges are born
of dominance and they impact news
publishers of every type
no matter the form of ownership or
ideological balance of their editorial
pages
in thinking about the future of news too
often we get pulled back
into debates about past business models
i'm here to ask a question about the
future do we want professional local
journalism to continue to be available
to the public or don't we
because if we maintain our current path
we will see the
ultimate destruction of quality local
news for most of the public
without any rational expectation of
alternatives or new entrants
hope is not a strategy nor is it the
basis for sustainable market
for news we need solutions now
so what do we need from congress first
and foremost local news
publishers need the ability to
collectively negotiate
with the major platforms as contemplated
by the journalism competition and
preservation act
in the face of dominant intermediaries
it is unconscionable to prevent
publishers from working together to
fight for their own future
and the publishers most in need of
collective action are local and
community publishers
who have no individual capacity to
assert their value against the major
platforms
but experience from around the world has
now taught us that this might not be
enough
as we've seen in europe and australia
when pressed
google and facebook will refuse to
negotiate
threaten in some cases actually cut off
access to news content
and offer limited compensation to
selected publishers in an attempt to
forestall legislation
we should all understand that these
actions are in and of themselves
fundamental expressions of market
dominance
we would suggest that the congress
consider expansions of the jcpa
that would include an oversight
mechanism to ensure good faith
negotiations by the platforms
that would result in equitable treatment
for local and community publishers
and that any compensation model reward
investments made by publishers
in journalists and journalism such a
system could be structured in a variety
of different ways
but fundamentally it would be a limited
and focused response to the
to the challenge of ensuring a future
for local journalism
all we're really asking for is a fair
chance to fight for ourselves and our
futures
thank you again very much and i look
forward to your questions
i thank the gentleman for his testimony
the chair now recognizes mr smith for
five minutes for his opening statement
thank you chairman cecillini ranking
member buck other members of the
committee it's a pleasure for me to be
here and let me say as well thank you
representative jayapal for that kind
introduction from a
neighboring washingtonian um let me
first
say the obvious microsoft is a tech
company and like every business
we have business interests there are
some steps this subcommittee could take
that will make us more challenging in
our business it may make it more costly
to do business there are other steps the
subcommittee could take that will help
us
in our business and yet i have to say
what is also obvious is this
the issues before this committee are not
about our business or
any single business they are about an
issue far
bigger than that they're about the
future of journalism
in this country and if one thing is
clear it's this
for almost 250 years journalism
has been a lifeblood of democracy
and this is especially true at the local
level local news
plays critical roles in telling people
about what their school board is
considering or
exposing corruption in public office
but it does a lot more than that too it
tells an
entire community about what's going to
happen at the county fair
or about the high school band or about a
church retreat
i think it's really interesting alexis
de tocqueville was one of the first
tourists if you will to visit america
this was in 1835 and after
visiting community after community he
talked about the role that newspapers
played in preserving freedom and then he
said this
to suppose that they serve only to
protect freedom is to diminish their
importance they maintain civilization
that is true the news maintains
american civilization but as you noted
sherman cislini the news in america
today is not
alive and well almost every american
knows from an early age that we are a
country of 50 states
but we're also a nation of 3142 counties
and it is at the county level and in
cities and towns that communities
and people live their lives and yet
after the decline the collapse of more
than 2000 newspapers
we now live in a nation where almost
half of our counties are down to one
newspaper
at best 1 540 of those counties 200 of
which have no
newspaper at all and of everything i
have read about the state of journalism
in america and its impact nothing is
more impactful to me than
the statement of a citizen in florida we
talked about what had happened after
they had lost their local newspaper and
he said
after several years without a strong
local voice
our community does not know itself
how do we maintain civilization how do
we protect democracy if our communities
no longer know
themselves that is the issue to be
addressed
we all know how this has happened it's
because of technology technology that in
so many ways including from my own
company we believe has done so many good
things for the country and the world
and yet it's also perfectly clear that
what was previously advertising revenue
for newspapers
has instead moved to advertising revenue
for tech companies
and in fact what we've seen is the
decline in advertising revenue for
newspapers fall from
48 billion dollars to 14.
that is a deep hole that no one has been
able to make up
so what do we do that is the question of
the day and i'll offer three thoughts
first i think that
you all are on the right path that's why
microsoft is endorsing
the journalism competition and
protection act the jcpa
to give news organizations the ability
to
negotiate collectively including with
microsoft
because as presently drafted we will be
subject to its terms
second i think it's good to consider
additional ideas including ideas that
we've worked with
recently firsthand in australia ideas
that would impose on tech companies an
obligation to bargain in good faith to
avoid retaliation to be transparent
about their practices
these are worthy of competition in
consideration
by the antitrust subcommittee and
finally
i hope that the subcommittee will
continue its work to think more broadly
about the
fundamental lack of competition
especially in search and digital
advertising
that are at the heart of not just the
decline in journalism but the decline in
challenge in many sectors of the economy
that too is worthy of consideration when
it comes to potential new legislation
in short the issues are big the needs
are urgent the time is now
and we welcome the opportunity to be
part of this
thank you thank you mr smith we are
really grateful for your testimony i now
recognize mr schloss
for five minutes
chairman cecillini ranking member bach
and members of the subcommittee thank
you so much for having me today
my name is john schloyce and i'm
president of the news guild cwa and i'm
here to tell you about the extinction
level event workers are facing in the
news industry
we're the largest union of journalists
in the united states with thousands of
news workers among our membership
at large publications like the
washington post and the new york times
but also with small ones
like the billings gazette in montana and
the jacksonville florida times union
we're part of the larger union the
communications workers of america
i grew up in rural south arkansas and i
remember as a kid
my grandmother got two newspapers every
day in the morning she got the arkansas
democrat gazette
and in the afternoon she got the camden
news fast forward to my first full-time
job in the industry which ended up being
at the arkansas democratic gazette as
their online editor
i have a background both in computer
programming and in journalism
and i fused my skills to help us
transition from printed newspapers
to better news online but two months
into my job
the head of the company pulled everyone
into a room and told us that we were
merging with our competing
newspaper within a couple of months
hundreds of people
lost their jobs i remember seeing
reporters
mothers and fathers crying in offices
not knowing what their futures were
going to look like
that was a quick introduction into the
radical shift in the news industry
that's been my life and that's been the
life of so many journalists across our
country
cuts consolidation and local news
sources getting bought out
and gutted at that time i was told that
for every dollar that that newspaper
brought
in 90 cents of it came from advertising
print advertising
today things are radically different in
the last 16 years 2 100
newsrooms across the country have shut
down and there are half as many
newspaper journals working today as
there were a decade ago
that's 36 000 journalists no longer
working in cities and towns across the
united states
not covering city council meetings not
covering school boards
not providing communities a voice the
pandemic and widespread economic pain
across the country has sped
up the revenue losses and newsrooms and
90 cents that
newspapers used to earn that's gone too
as revenue
print revenue is dried up and digital
advertising is raked in by almost
just two companies google and facebook
that revenue loss
resulting from the platform's dominant
market position has left many newsrooms
in a weakened financial condition
and that's left them vulnerable to take
over by predatory financial actors who
don't care about local news
they only care about cash extraction and
they accomplish that by strip mining
local news outlets and cutting
local staff what's left are ghost
newspapers or no
news coverage at all and these hedge
funds like alden global capital are
gutting
people off from knowing what's happening
in their communities and eroding our
democracy
albans gobbled up local newspapers and
gutted them great institutions like the
denver post and the saint paul pioneer
press
and the orange county register at 12
publications where we have data alden
cut staff by more than
75 since 2012 faster than the already
devastating industry decline
the journalism competition and
preservation act accurately identifies
the problem of excessive market power of
facebook and google and we appreciate
the bill's focus on rectifying the core
power imbalance between those platforms
and the news companies
google and facebook benefit from the
stories produced by journalists and they
use that traffic to sell ads
capturing a majority of the digital ad
revenue the company should pay their
fair share when benefiting from sharing
of news stories
however because many news companies put
shareholder profits above our
communities
we need specific enforceable
requirements to make sure that
additional revenue is tied to local news
jobs we recommend that at least 60 of
any added revenue generated through
collective industry bargaining be
dedicated to new jobs
and further we experienced a wave of
unionization in the past three years
with thousands of workers organizing to
protect their jobs and their
publications
organization receiving additional
revenue must be required to bargain in
good faith
and remain neutral when workers want to
organize a union
we also want to ensure that medium and
smaller publications benefit because the
industry's
so consolidated even just in the past
two years five companies several of them
controlled by hedge funds owned one
third of america's daily newspapers
and half of all newspaper circulation in
addition to taking on the tech
platform's predatory behavior
we must also address the attacks on
local news by vultures like alden by
passing the stop wall street looting act
the crisis
in local news is a crisis of democracy
congress needs to use its power to
respond to the crisis for the good
of our country thank you thank you mr
schloss and i apologize for the
mispronunciation
i won't uh get that wrong again uh i now
recognize ms barr for five minutes
good morning chairman sisolini and
ranking member buck members of the
subcommittee my name is emily barr and
i'm the president and ceo of graham
media group
owner of seven local television stations
i appreciate the opportunity to testify
on behalf of the national association of
broadcasters
and its nearly 7 200 free and local
television and radio station
members in your hometowns broadcasters
represent one of the last bastions of
truly local unbiased journalism
information that is still respected by
all americans your constituents turn to
their local reporters and anchors for
voices they trust legislative action
including swift passage of the
journalism competition and preservation
act
is needed to preserve this essential
cornerstone of our democracy
this past year challenged us to myriad
ways but among the most painful for many
americans
was the isolation they experienced
detachment from their families neighbors
and communities
when it was needed most local television
and radio stations provided the civic
bond
for the communities we serve doing
incredible work in the face of our own
enormous challenges we continue to be
the primary source of the
community-focused information
on which your constituents have relied
during this pandemic
how do i keep my family safe when and
where can i get vaccinated
when can i visit my grandparents when
can my children safely go back to school
these are the questions that we help our
viewers and listeners navigate every day
this past year has also tested our
democracy and the very pillars upon
which it stands
including a free and diverse press due
in large part to the misinformation
circulating unchecked
in the digital ecosystem more and more
americans have lost faith in the
information reaching their eyes and ears
fortunately local broadcasters remain a
touchstone for the truth
and are the most trusted sources of
information in the country
i am proud the grain media stations
exemplify this commitment to community
and truth
for example floridians who were recently
shut out by the state's failed
unemployment system
did what americans do when there's no
one else to turn to they called upon
their local broadcaster
wkmg in orlando answered that call
shining a light on that crisis and
creating the publicity and pressure
needed to put nearly a million dollars
in unpaid benefits
back into the hands of floridians
entitled to them i've spent
over four decades on local broadcast
television working in virtually every
capacity from the newsroom to the
boardroom
and i understand the significant cost of
producing quality journalism
but quality journalism delivered through
our uniquely free service
has only been made possible over many
decades through advertising revenues
as you all are aware these revenues have
experienced a free fall in recent years
due almost exclusively to the rapid
often anti-competitive
expansion of the dominant online
platforms the market power of the tech
platforms
undermines the online advertising model
the local broadcast journalism in two
important ways
first the tech platform's role as
content gatekeepers stifles our ability
to generate user traffic
second anti-competitive term service and
a take it or leave it approach
leave local broadcasters with a below
market sliver of those ad revenues
for local broadcasters and our viewers
and listeners this is a catch-22
to attract online user traffic we must
be accessible through the major
platforms
yet the terms of access dictated by the
platforms
devalue our products even more
concerning
is the degree to which certain platforms
commoditize news content
with little regard for the quality and
veracity of the story
this puts fact-based reporting like ours
on par with unsubstantiated click bait
as we fight for user eyeballs in both
platform news feeds
and traditional search the result is a
dangerous focus
on catchy headlines and viral stories
over quality journalism
this market transformation has been
exacerbated by deliberate decisions on
the part of the tech platforms
to put technological and systemic
roadblocks in the way of broadcasters
trying to gain access to these platforms
the barriers to entry erected by the
major platforms take on many forms
for example decisions about which
content will be prioritized by
algorithms
often favor sensationalism and
misinformation over hard journalism
platforms decide unilaterally which
content can be monetized
and how much revenue they will share as
a result the dominant online platforms
have flourished
siphoning off huge amounts of
advertising revenues that are the
lifeblood of free local journalism
one significant step toward curing these
harms would be the passage of the jcpa
nab strongly supports this targeted
common sense proposal
which would give broadcasters and other
news publishers the ability to level the
playing field in negotiations with the
tech giants
in addition to the jcpa nab looks
forward to working with congress
to explore additional policy remedies to
ensure that journalists and news
organizations
are fairly compensated for the reporting
and content they create
recognizing the inherent value of this
original content
thank you again for the opportunity to
appear before you today i look forward
to your questions thank you so much miss
ball for your testimony i now recognize
mr greenwald for five minutes
good morning chairman cecilini rank
member buck members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
participate
in these hearings my name is glenn
greenwald and the work i have been doing
for
the last 25 years first for a decade or
so as a constitutional lawyer and then
for the last 15 years
as a journalist uh somebody who has
done much investigative reporting that
has provoked the ire of many governments
around the world
uh who has co-founded a media outlet in
2013
and helped to grow it through 2020 in
this very difficult climate
and as a co-founder of the freedom of
the press foundation
devoted to defending the rights of
journalists to be free
of government retaliation i have a
really passionate and deep
uh and long-standing interest in the
issues before this committee
i think as well that this subcommittee
has done some of the most important work
particularly with the october report in
documenting the serious menace that
silicon valley
monopoly power uh has not just for our
political life but for the flow
information and increasingly
other sectors of our life and i
certainly agree with
everyone who has spoken before me about
the serious problem
of particularly local news outlets
failing as a result of
their inability to find a financial
model to sustain themselves
in this climate and nonetheless do you
have concerns
about the proposed solution pending
before the subcommittee
if you look at the last five or six
months i believe
strongly that the problem of silicon
valley
use of their monopoly power interference
and control are put up has worsened
quite severely
three incidents in particular that i
define and describe in my opening
statement
one being what congressman jordan
referred to
as the censorship of what turned out to
be
completely accurate reporting based on
authentic and genuine documents
broken by the new york post the nation's
oldest newspaper
about the front-running presidential
candidate in the weeks leading up to the
election by twitter
simply banning any discussion of that
story and the locking that newspaper
out of its account unless they agreed to
delete all references to their own
reporting
and facebook algorithmically suppressing
the ability for that story to spread
was an extremely disturbing example of
the ability
of giants to interfere in our elections
the same took place
with the removal of the sitting
president of the united states which
although supported by many united states
was condemned by world leaders
including many who had a very
adversarial relationship with president
trump uh chancellor merkel
in germany uh the president of mexico
french and eu officials on the grounds
that
tech giants are posing a threat not just
to american democracy
but to world democracy the concern that
i have is that often we talk about
the relationship between journalists and
the media industry on the one hand
and tech giants on the other as a
predator-prey relationship where the
tech giants are the predators
and the news industry is the prey but
oftentimes that's not the case
if you look at the most serious and
disturbing instances
of tech censorship over the past six to
12 months
one would expect based on the
traditional model
of news media to uphold the values that
chairman cecilia referred to as a free
and diverse press
to condemn oppose that kind of
censorship and yet the opposite
happened oftentimes the journalists were
not only supporters of it after the fact
but leading proponents of it beforehand
pressuring these tech companies
to censor and to silence ideologies with
which they disagree or competitors
to these organizations i'm concerned in
particular that by empowering
a news media that believes not
necessarily any longer in a free and
diverse press but in idle ideological
homogeneity
that they can use this new power to
impose
these values of censorship of silencing
news outlets with which they disagree in
the name of quality control
and i'm particularly worried that we
have a news media that is becoming
itself
increasingly concentrated where the new
york times is essentially becoming like
the amazon
of journalism this subcommittee issued a
report
filled with extremely uh promising and i
think
important solutions to the problem of
monopolistic power and i'm concerned
that if the subcommittee instead starts
taking a piecemeal approach
to appease and aggrandize the most
powerful industries like journalists
it could forestall the opportunity to
get to the
root of the problem that is concerning
people across the ideological spectrum
which is the need to apply antitrust
laws
to these growing monopolies not in a
case by case basis
but overall so i hope the committee
stays focused on on its outstanding
report that it issued and thanks again
for the opportunity
the gentleman yields back i now
recognize mr travis for five minutes
chairman cicilline members of the
subcommittee i appreciate you having us
all here
today to talk about an incredibly
important subject
that impacts all of us democrats
republicans independents
alike nearly 10 years ago i started my
own company
having no idea what direction media was
going to move
that company outkick.com is now one of
the largest sports and opinion
independent websites in the country
we've had a great deal
of success i also host a daily sports
talk radio show
from 6 to 9 a.m eastern all 50 states
300 plus
am fm stations and on august the 11th
president of the united states came on
my radio program
he came on because he wanted to talk
about the need for college football
and college sports to be played this
fall not a particularly partisan issue
we talked about the nba we talked about
the nfl we talked about sports
as the nation experiences sports the day
after
the president came on my radio show
we covered that day august the 11th the
stories that came out of that interview
aggressively as anyone would who had the
president of the united states
on their radio show the day after
that interview facebook tanked
our traffic the data in the appendixes
that
that we attached for you show that the
next day
and over the next week facebook removed
68
of our audience 76
of our new users that cost my company
hundreds of thousands of dollars
to me it was clear content-based
speech discrimination facebook didn't
like that we had the president of the
united states
on our radio program and they also
didn't like that the majority of the
coverage of that interview
was positive which as a sports fan
it's hard to be negative when the favor
of the president
is aligned with games actually being
played
that to me is an interesting anecdote
into the overwhelming power
that we have given to the big tech
companies
in this country it doesn't stop there
either
there's an interesting thing that
happened to us
just in the last couple of weeks some of
you may have read
an editorial in the wall street journal
by a man named dr mackery
who is a johns hopkins doctor highly
qualified his opinion
written on the editorial page of the
wall street journal newspaper
his opinion was that based on
the current rate of vaccination as well
as the people who had already been
exposed to covid
it was likely by the end of april that
herd immunity would be
reached in this country certainly some
scientists and doctors agree with that
certainly some scientists and doctors
disagree with that opinion
we wrote about that editorial opinion
on our website the article
was not in any way complicated
or difficult in fact our headline was
straightforward
johns hopkins medical professional heard
immunity will be here
by april we published that on facebook
within a matter of days we received a
notification from facebook
with the downright orwellian subject
important notification misinformation
violation facebook told us
that we were not allowed to share the
opinion
of a doctor on our website because they
said it was a fact check inaccuracy
it was members of the subcommittee
an opinion an opinion
of a reasoned and well learned
doctor that is what the scientific
method is we
argue about what the truth is in this
country with an idea that we reach
a better conclusion facebook's own
fact checkers labeled our article about
an opinion to be factually inaccurate
which is an impossibility who checks
the fact checkers our traffic declined
by 80 as you can see as soon as facebook
found
this violation we would all be rightly
concerned
if the government of the united states
was making these kind of decisions
my concern is all of the big tech
companies now
have the same power that china has
to regulate the internet in its country
instead of the government doing it
we have allowed big tech to do it i
thank you and look forward to your
questions
i thank the gentleman for his testimony
and now we will proceed under the
five-minute rule
and i'll begin by recognizing mr mr
nagoose
from colorado for five minutes
thank you uh mr chairman can you hear me
yes we can okay great thank you
mr chairman and also chairman nadler for
holding this timely hearing and examine
legislative proposals
to help local journalism and small
publishers compete in the digital
marketplace and i want to thank chairman
cecilini
you in particular for your leadership in
this area colorado which is the state
that i represent
in congress is all too familiar with the
decline and closure of local newspaper
outlets
the rocky mountain news closed a little
over 12 years ago the rocky as
locals affectionately called it was a
newspaper before colorado was admitted
into the union
since then we witnessed the denver post
become acquired by a hedge fund which
led to layoffs and cost cutting measures
in the last
10 years we've gone from having two
legacy newspapers
upwards of 500 journalists covering
local and national issues
to having one legacy newspaper with
roughly 70 journalists on staff
the reason why these trends are
concerning is obvious and we've heard
the compelling case from
many of the witnesses today it's because
local journalism and democracy go hand
in hand
and simply put the american experiment
cannot work if the voters are not
informed on their communities and their
leaders and so with that i want to thank
each of the witnesses for being here and
want to thank them for their thoughtful
testimony
i want to start with a question that
is relevant to my state as i mentioned
in colorado the denver post uh went
through with the massive layoffs and
budget cuts
what budget cuts once their parent
company was acquired by
a hedge fund alvin global capital one
post reporter
mentioned that the post had quote 70
people covering a metro area of about
three million people
mr is this situation unique to the
denver post
and can you provide the committee with
more context on how the aggressive
squeeze
on ad revenues by tech giants really
spurs predatory behavior
uh that we've seen from some of these
hedge funds to essentially gut
local news absolutely so we've seen um
you know as a shift from revenue for a
lot of local newspapers is shifted away
from
from getting a majority of the revenue
from print advertising
um and less and less uh as digital
uh platforms like google and facebook
take that up um it's allowed
large private equity groups like alden
global capital swoop in so it's not just
the denver post but
you know other places we represent
members of the east bay times in
california the san jose mercury news in
california the monterey herald
the saint paul pioneer press minnesota
the goal for a lot of these hedge funds
is to get
profits margins up to a point that's
not sustainable get them up above 16 get
them up to 20
by getting rid of any assets selling off
the real estate to other companies and
in their control
cutting staff as much as possible and
right now they're in the process of
trying to acquire
another large publisher tribune
publishing which has
about a dozen newspapers from chicago to
allentown pennsylvania to hartford
uh into orlando florida they just want
to get profits up as high as possible
and we'll do that by cutting
staff and cutting local news coverage
thank you it's a follow-up question the
logical section would be
what legislative proposals do you think
this committee ought to consider
uh to help mitigate against some of
these primary practices
by these uh these companies so i think
you know
looking at just even the idea of these
takeovers and mergers right we're at the
point where the industry is
super consolidated and under extreme
financial pressure by just a handful of
actors
so looking at any potential mergers and
finding ways to create legislation that
would
incorporate the idea of how will this
affect local news coverage
if this merger were to take place what
would it do to the local jobs and the
economy because when we lose
local news outlets across the country no
matter whether they're in
blue districts or red districts taxes go
up corruption goes up and partisanship
goes up as people have
few and fewer outlets for facts so that
would be one effort another thing is
provide incentives
let's let's get hedge funds out by being
providing incentives to get them to
donate to
foundations or nonprofits so that we can
have sustainable
community accountable local news
thank you and uh with that again i would
say thank you to the
chairman and also to the ranking member
for their leadership on this important
issue
and uh look forward to both of them on
this front and with that i would yield
back the balance of my time
the gentleman yields back and now
recognize the ranking member
of the subcommittee mr buck i i thank
the the chair for rank uh recognize me
and i ask the chair to recognize mr
gates and i will
uh ask questions uh at the end if that's
okay of course
mr gates is now recognized for five
minutes
thank you mr chairman and uh as usual
your approach to the way our americans
interact with these monopolistic
platforms continues to be
bipartisan and thoughtful and i thank
you for that
i'm a co-sponsor of the jcpa but after
hearing some of the testimony i'm
wondering
whether i should be not every failure
of every local news entity is a failure
of democracy
sometimes it's just bad news sometimes
the people who work in local journalism
are the ones creating as what ms graham
described
unsubstantiated clickbait and so we
cannot we cannot view it
that that way mr greenwald i have
some questions for you uh and i'll i'll
confess at the beginning
though you once said i have quote the
worst
ideology in congress i am a ravenous
consumer of
your content i find it all very thought
thought provoking
uh and i i read you on sub stack
frequently
but i want to ask i want to go into one
of the elements of your testimony
where you talked about the potential for
the jcpa
to create a stratus a stratification
within media
where you create more distance between
the large media conglomerates like
you know ganette or news corp and then
maybe those
smaller more independent sites that are
also creating good news
are you worried that by trying to
remedy the monopolies in big tech
we create greater challenges in the
monopolies of big media
and make it even harder for independent
uh gritty journalism to survive
i do worry about that quite a bit uh
congressman gates
if you we've listened to many people
speak quite accurately about the state
of
the news industry today and what we're
hearing is not a kind of idealized or
romanticized
picture that we might like to think
about of having a
a diverse and and dispersed uh
power throughout the industry where
lots of different voices can be heard
but instead a very concentrated
industry very similar in fact to silicon
valley maybe a few steps behind it
such that if you empower this industry
without
including enormous numbers of big clear
and concrete safeguards to prevent it
you could very well be essentially
accelerating some of the worst industry
trends
ensuring that say hedge funds who
control the industries or
media giants that exert overwhelming
power like the new york times or digital
outlets
can further entrench their power through
this
negotiating force that becomes an
anti-trust exemption
in a way that i'm concerned will
exacerbate the problems that
the subcommittee is correctly
identifying as a problem
but also forestall the longer term
solutions of dealing with silicon valley
monopolistic power
that is at the root of all of these
problems yeah
and in that regard you seem to agree
with the fundamental premise laid out by
chairman sissolini and ranking member
buck i mean you you are one of the
founders of the intercept
as a result of the intercept not liking
some of your criticism of the political
left
you had to leave the entity you
co-founded you go to sub-stack to write
and now even at sub-stack their efforts
underway to
to cancel and and censor journalists who
are critical of other journalists and so
if the remedy that mr uh sicily and mr
buck have proposed is not the right one
uh what what insight would you offer in
order to
get at the core problem the concern i
have
is that the discussion in the
legislation seems
grounded in a premise that the only or
the primary problem
of both local and national journalism is
that google and facebook are vacuuming
up
advertising revenue and if you simply
fix that problem the problem of
uh media failure will be rectified as
well and i don't think that's true i
think there's reasons why
consumers have turned away from
journalism
i'm concerned that legislation like this
can prevent the self-examination
of why journalism has failed so many
people why people no longer trust it
and put their faith in it and i do
absolutely
believe that the problem of silicon
valley monopolistic power
and its ability to interfere in our our
politics and to impede a free press
is a very serious one but oftentimes
it's the media itself it's journalists
themselves who are demanding that that
power be exercised in a sensorious way
that
undermines a free and diverse class and
that's why i think that
until the problem that this subcommittee
identified in that report is addressed
head-on
which is breaking up the monopoly powers
of this industry
none of these problems will will will
really be fixed
and oftentimes these piecemeal solutions
can make them much worse by empowering
an industry that's causing many of them
in the first place
thank you for that thoughtful feedback
thank you for your indulgence mr
chairman i'll submit my
additional questions to the witnesses
for the record and i yield back thank
you mr gizmo
i just want to make a quick point here
if it's okay i i do think that people
should understand that
consumers have not turned away from
journalism they're consuming it at a
higher rate than ever before and
the bill that at least mr buck and i
have put forth as well as a number of
colleagues on the subcommittee
provides a temporary fix for a 48-month
period
and in fact anything these larger media
companies would negotiate would be
available to the smallest rural
newspaper
in any city in town in america which i
think protects against some of the
concerns that
mr greenwald mentioned so i think you
know we've thought about that and i
think the bill
responds that and finally i just said
that with respect to the larger
challenges of
anti-trust and monopolization the
committee intends to be very active on
all of the solutions contained in our
report uh we're not going to do either
or we're going to do both so i just want
to reassure the witnesses of that
and with that i recognize the
distinguished gentleman from the state
of new york mr jones for five minutes
thank you mr chairman and also the
ranking member
for your bipartisan leadership on this
issue
and of course thanks to all of our
witnesses for your testimony this
morning
i'm glad we have a bill before us as i
alluded to with such
strong bipartisan support since today's
hearing is about saving
free and diverse press i want to center
a topic we haven't heard
enough about thus far and that is the
importance of journalism
by and for communities of color as the
advertising market consolidates
we need to stand up for the media
serving communities of color
in my district that means publications
like black westchester
and aj woodson founded black westchester
with a mission
and that mission is providing a platform
for westchester counties communities of
color
that's especially important in
westchester county which has a long
history of housing discrimination
and remains under a federal consent
decree
to desegregate its neighborhoods in
westchester
the mortality rate for the counties
black infants is four times higher
than for white infants and police arrest
15
times more black people for cannabis
possession than white people even though
black people
and white people use the drugs
all too often westchester officials and
local media conversations
weren't reaching communities of color or
listening to them
today black westchester helps bridge
that gap
that's why black westchester has always
been available online for free
if they put up a paywall they'd exclude
the very people they're working to serve
so to fulfill their mission they depend
on advertising
but lately that ad revenue is harder and
harder to come by
and the challenging financial conditions
black westchester is confronting
are typical of the conditions that
similar publications are confronting
throughout the country
now this committee's 2020 majority staff
report is clear
facebook and google wield monopoly power
over digital advertising
and as a result over the freedom and
diversity of the press and the future of
our democracy
two big tech companies shouldn't have
the power to decide whether
and how black voices or the voices of
any other marginalized communities are
hurt
that power should belong to us mr
whitson put the problem perfectly
quote independent free and diverse press
like us
how do we survive uh so mr schweiz since
you mentioned this issue in your written
testimony let me ask you
how will the journalism competition and
preservation act help local publications
by and for people and other marginalized
communities
so i think you know the the
recommendation that i put forward that
we
actually make sure that we're targeting
as much as we can to jobs would help
go in that direction i mean this is this
is a huge problem that we have
um one of the major issues that folks
organize unions around
because their newsrooms actually don't
even look like the communities
that they serve right the demographics
are way out of whack
um so i think two one of the things that
that congress needs to focus on is
making sure that there are ways
for non-profit or foundation support for
uh communities of color to make sure
that we actually cover
and uh and support those voices because
it goes back to whether
you have a publication in a big city or
or not
in a small town it's it's a question of
making sure that there's accountability
there
that it looks like the community and
that it's actually giving that community
a voice regardless of race or ethnicity
thanks mr vern finally if the
fundamental problem of facebook and
google are their monopoly power
shouldn't all options be on the table
including breaking them up
well certainly i mean we've been
supportive of
the uh certainly the committee's work on
antitrust and
the judicial actions on antitrust but a
couple things
those antitrust actions take a very long
time right
many of these anti-trust trials won't
start for years
uh we have an immediate problem and to
your earlier question
uh the the ones most in need of
collective action are small and
community publishers and
including most particularly publishers
of color who
who are uh suffering deeply in this
broken marketplace
for real quality journalism i mean this
is a product
that is critically important to
communities it's more popular than ever
but the system itself isn't rewarding
and that's not just
a question of where the ad dollars go
that's a question of dominance from
two plat two tech companies so if we
want
diverse voices of every perspective we
need a market
for news content that works and that
sustains
new entrants and diverse voices and we
don't have that now this is
most particularly a problem for small
and community publishers of every type
thank you mr chairman i yield back the
gentleman yields back i now recognize
the gentleman from california mr isa for
five minutes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
holding this hearing i think it gives us
an opportunity to look
at what is clear a pervasive problem uh
i have not signed on to this particular
solution and i have a lot of questions
uh probably the most notable question is
why is this not a joint hearing with the
intellectual property and courts
subcommittee since clearly what we're
talking about
is negotiating over one organization's
statutory
intellectual property uh and finding a
solution
but nevertheless i'd like to talk
primarily to the two witnesses are here
in person
mr greenwald i'm going to try to make
this rapid
uh i'm mr travis i'm sorry
mr travis been confused for worse trust
me
yeah mr mr travis thank you uh
have you uh have you ever read uh atlas
shrugged
or fountain head a long time ago yes sir
mr smith i assume you have too parts of
it a long time ago yeah
okay well i when i was listening to uh
uh the witnesses i i heard
quite frankly exactly that rather than
the courts deciding an entry trust
problem and solution i heard governments
saying
and uh in the case of uh
i think both uh graham media and uh
the news guild uh what they were saying
was that we need to take an industry
that is
uh that is losing and we need to give
them money from an industry that is
winning
in order to preserve that industry that
is going away
not withstanding whether that's right or
wrong did anyone hear anything
differently here
well what i would say is while there may
be an element of that i think there are
two
dimensions that change the normal
situation
number one we're talking about an
industry that is suffering because of
changes in
competition that rightly can and should
be addressed through antitrust law
and number two we're not talking about
just any
industry under this and mr smith i
appreciate that but
you know one of my challenges is in fact
that all the way back with iran
uh we we were taught a lesson which is
that when government starts to pick
winners and losers
there's no end in sight and that that's
one of my concerns here
is are we picking winners and losers and
i think i think we clearly are
now there's no question at all that
these companies own their intellectual
property
and in fact we may want to give them
additional rights to uh to protect that
property
and uh mr smith i'll i'll pose a
question to you
um currently uh if
google copy searches your copyrights and
makes that available
do you have any objection do you need to
monetize any and all of your
copyrighted material that that they go
through
and and create searches for i'm talking
about microsoft's own copyrighted
material
um we may not have objections with
respect to the monetization or lack
thereof for our content but
look we're not in the news business so i
don't think that
you know what is true for us actually is
all that relevant well and let's
let's go through the news for a moment
uh and we'll stick to news for a moment
uh in 1982 and i'll i'll go to mr
greenwald
uh in 1982 the cleveland press went out
of business
and cleveland went from two daily
newspapers to one
was that because of the internet as far
as you know
no the internet did not exist in 1982.
in fact were newspapers
diminishing and consolidating throughout
the
60s 70s 80s and 90s rather than
expanding particularly the classic
daily citywide newspaper i
i think to a large extent that is true i
i think
when you look and the broader question
that you're asking as i think a good one
can you create and fix anti-trust
violations which i think are existing
from big tech companies now
by creating an anti-trust exemption
for others this is such a complex issue
that that seems to me to be
a really i understand the intent and i
think the intent is
is a good one but the challenge of cr
correcting anti-trust power by creating
anti-trust exemptions
seems to me to be an inherent difficulty
and and i very much agree and i'm not
trying to
uh uh disagree with the problem just
question some of the solution
let me just ask a question for anyone
that wants to with the remaining few
minutes
the new york times the la times the
washington post have any of those
organizations ever said put things out
in print that were untrue or
or chose not to print things which were
true yes
okay so if they do it then we're really
not talking about a difference
in the case of facebook or google or any
of the others what we're talking about
is who did it in the 18th and 19th
century with impunity
and who may be doing it today because of
its market power is that true
the uh gentleman uh the time the drama
has expired but witness wants to answer
quickly
you may do so if you understand the
question
we're not talking about when or who did
it we're talking about what laws apply
to it
that's what i would say this is about
thank you the gentleman yields back
the chair now recognizes mr deutsch of
florida for five minutes uh
thank you mr chairman uh mr chairman
towards the end of his life
uh legendary journalists uh and
america's most
trusted name in news walter cronkite
said i think it is
absolutely essential in a democracy to
have competition in the media
a lot of competition and we seem to be
moving away from that
over a decade since his death we can
agree that his warning
was an extreme understatement the harm
that anti-competitive practices
of technology platforms like facebook
and google sometimes
feel very abstract but the value of a
free and diverse press
especially local news media has a very
tangible impact on our lives and on our
communities
local investigative journalism can root
out corruption bring attention to issues
that matter in our communities but that
don't and will never attract national
attention
in the three years since the shooting at
marjory stoneman douglas high school we
saw the story fade from national
headlines but
local outlets like the south florida sun
sentinel
were exhaustively investigating the
failures that contributed to that awful
day
important work that was recognized for
the pulitzer prize and our community has
worked in
our shared brief to keep alive the
memory of the seventeen we lost that day
their hobbies their passions their
character
and it's the work of the sun center and
the palm beach coast the miami herald
the local broadcasters
other local news media that's been an
important part of telling these stories
and demanding accountability on the
other hand
facebook google other technology
platforms
played an instrumental role in spreading
misinformation and conspiracy theories
about
the tragic event that day and many
others
and i've asked google on facebook and
twitter and hearings before the
judiciary committee why
why they keep giving not just a platform
but
a megaphone to people who spread lies
about the shooting
in my district the people who target
children survivors
and their families we need more
responsible high quality journalism and
fewer
monetized megaphones that some
use to attempt to destroy lies mr
schabern
how do we rebalance the scale what are
the main components of making
online platforms take more
responsibility for the content
they carry and leveling the playing
field between news publishers
and online platforms so that high
quality content
gets elevated over conspiracies and
misinformation
great thank you very much uh congressman
uh two things i agree with you by the
way we want competition in the news
media but
uh we currently have a market that
suppresses it it makes it impossible to
develop
new entrants and competitive voices new
diverse voices
uh you know if you were going to build a
new entrant in local news
you're facing a marketplace dominated by
two companies
that suppresses the value of that
content makes it impossible to have new
entrants secondly
uh specifically to your point we i've
talked in other contexts about the role
that section 230
plays uh in the ecosystem and in
particular
uh the platform's role in amplifying
uh content the choices the platforms
make to decide
what gets seen and what doesn't get seen
too often i think the discussion is
about
whether a particular piece of content
should be labeled or moderated or take
down
and that avoids the question about what
the platforms do the choices they make
and the responsibilities they should
have
about the choices they make so i would
say
two things one we need a fair uh
capacity for news publishers to improve
the market
for quality news content and we have to
look at the responsibilities that the
platform should have
for their decisions about amplifying
them
thanks thanks trevor ms barr
i mentioned the harm to communities and
harmed individuals who are the targets
of
lives but your testimony raised a good
point about the damage
posed to responsible news outlets with
the placement of responsible journalism
alongside
uh these uh these kinds of lies can you
just elaborate on the challenges that it
poses to your business
yes thank you very much congressman look
at what happens is we put our stories
online and
i can tell you that roughly 60 to 70
percent of what we put out there is
referred back to us
either by google or facebook so when
those stories sit online adjacent to
uh stories that might be misinformation
or outright lies clickbait whatever you
might want to call it
it literally diminishes our reputation
and makes people distrust or
causes some distrust so we then spend a
lot of time
trying to um ensure that our viewers
and our users understand that we've
researched
we have trained journalists we know what
it is we're trying to say and
we have to also then go back and look at
the stories that are
incorrect and make sure they understand
that those aren't
um uh you know aren't uh uh believable
but it's really difficult because as we
all know a lie goes around the world
very quickly
uh thanks i'm miss bar and mr chairman
thank you for holding this important
hearing and thanks to all of the
witnesses
uh the testimony of every one of you is
really helpful and instructed i yield
back
thank you the gentleman yields back i
now recognize the gentleman from oregon
mr bentz
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
this most interesting
meeting this first question is for mr
greenwald
it's been said about the newspaper
preservation act passed back in 1970
that
it was removing those so protected from
the judgment of the marketplace
it's also been said that it failed to
prevent abusive tactics failed to
help the smaller papers did little to
improve the quality
of the opinions and writings of
newspapers
can you share with me the difference
between that act the newspaper
preservation act and
and then the bill that we're we're
discussing today
well i think that uh this goes to the
comment that chairman cecilia made after
the last time i spoke
about how more and more people are
consuming news than ever before and i
think that if you ask people
inside the news industry virtually
everybody will acknowledge
that the reason for that is because of
what was essentially
sugar high of the last four years being
one of the most polarized
uh errors in american history because of
the person who
was occupying the oval office being so
controversial and that prior to that
there was a significant decline
in the number of people who were
trusting and
consuming news content ratings were
collapsing local papers were losing
subscriptions people were talking about
the new york times
going out of business and there was a
kind of
temporary event that intervened to save
the news industry then that sugar high
is now gone and if you look at
data there's no question that more and
more people
more than ever before distrust the media
precisely because so much of the
disinformation conspiracy theories and
falsehoods
come not from newly created sites online
but from the very industry that this
bill would essentially
empower by enabling them to act as a
consortium
thank you i'm not sure i heard to answer
my question there but i'm going to go to
mr smith
um mr smith has been reported in the
press that you were personally involved
in the discussions with the officials in
australia
including the prime minister what were
your takeaways from your involvement
and youth and and that you think might
be most relevant to
the issues we're discussing today well
thank you i actually think that there's
some
important takeaways from australia that
are very relevant to the conversation
taking place
and i'd actually go back to what mr ice
asked is this about picking winners and
losers and i would say no it is not
basically australia was addressing an
issue similar to the united states
the reason that publishers cannot
negotiate
collectively is because of laws passed
by congress
the clayton act of the fair trade
commission act
and so what australia did was give the
publishers
the ability to negotiate collectively
and so that's what this congress would
do it would mr isa going back to your
point
by passing the jcpa not pick somebody
new but address the unintended
consequences of what congress did in the
past
when it crafted antitrust laws that got
in the way
of these collective negotiations now the
other thing that i think is very
interesting and relevant from australia
is this what we're finding
is that the big publishers are not
interested in negotiating collectively
the three largest news organizations in
australia
are all negotiating separately it is the
small
publishers that are negotiating
collectively
and i basically believe that if this
congress passed the jcpa you'd have four
years to test the situation but in all
probability that's what you would find
here as well
thank you mr chair yield balance of my
time to mrisa
thank you i'd like to follow up on
exactly what you said
let's presume for a moment that we we
like this bill and we were going to pass
it
uh is there any reason that you wouldn't
limit the collectives to companies that
would be
under a certain amount of size in other
words limited to those
who inherently have limited market power
uh because here the wall street journal
the washington post and others probably
would turn away and say no we've got
we've got that handled
if this is if that is an issue that
concerns you i think that there are two
alternatives
to addressing one is to pass the bill as
uh drafted and you have four years and
then it
expires or you renew it the other is
craft
some exceptions so that it only applies
to say
a publication below a certain revenue
threshold
yeah either way i think you are
accomplishing what i believe
is your fundamental goal which is to
enable the small
publications of the country to be able
to negotiate collectively
well you know there's no smaller
business uh in most cases
than a recording artist so let me ask
one question the time of the gentleman i
would love to have but
maybe someone else can yield their time
but thank you generous expired
uh i now recognize the gentleman from
new york mr jefferies for five minutes
i thank the distinguished chair for
yielding as well as for your leadership
on this
issue along with the distinguished
gentleman from
colorado the ranking member justice
brandeis
once observed that in america we can
have
democracy or we can have wealth
concentrated in the hands of the very
few
but we can't have both i think it would
be fair to say
uh that it also seems to me to be the
case
uh that in america we can have democracy
or we can have
the emasculation of the free and fair
press
particularly at the local level but we
can't have both
and as the framers crafted this republic
and clearly
uh it's not a perfect union we're on the
march toward a more perfect
union they never promised a perfect
country they were imperfect themselves
but they clearly
understood the connectivity between the
free and fair press
our democracy liberty and the republic
uh that they were building there's a
reason why
uh the freedom of the press is in
the first amendment not the fifth the
10th the 15th
the 20th uh and thereafter
and so i appreciate this hearing and the
importance
uh of it to our democracy it seems to me
to be an existential
uh question uh ms barr you testified
that the
market power of the tech platforms uh
undermines the online advertising model
for local broadcast journalism can you
elaborate
uh on that particular point because i
think what's being said is not
that technology has changed and
you no longer can receive revenue
from the traditional print publications
it's that even in the context of
shifting to the digital platform
the current construct undermines your
ability to secure advertising revenue
can you
collaborate on that yes thank you
congressman jeffries um
so what i meant by that is that um in in
the current situation
a lot of our viewership which used to be
on television on linear television
has shifted to usership if you will
online
and in so doing we've seen our ratings
on tv go down
and while we do have more people
accessing us online
the value of the advertising that we
receive back online
is a fraction of what we've lost on the
television side
so we're spending considerably more
money to produce
and um and support what goes online it's
not just
taking the six o'clock news and we're
not putting it online we're literally
creating new content for online but
we're doing it at great cost
without being able to return the same
kind of revenue so as a result we're
just
spending more to get less thank you mr
smith i appreciate your testimony and
the support
of microsoft for this legislation as i
understand it this could
in some ways impact your business model
perhaps
in a somewhat adverse fashion
uh and so i'm interested mr smith in
uh your assessment as to why the company
has taken this position why you
think ultimately it's a good thing for
the country democracy and perhaps even
the free and fair flow of commerce well
i think it's clear under the
definitions in the legislation is
drafted
that news organizations would have the
right to negotiate collectively with
microsoft
because we would be an online content
distributor
we meet the the threshold of having more
than a billion
uh users per month for all of our online
services and websites put together
we do business with news publishers
today as i mentioned in my written
testimony we have an app we have a
service
we do business uh with you know hundreds
of publishers we serve that to
millions and millions of people and we
share revenue if this bill is passed
that means that these news organizations
would be able to negotiate collectively
with us i assume that they will
negotiate
effectively with us but the reality is
and i've said it at the end of my
written testimony
what we're talking about here and i
thought your reference to the first
amendment captured it perfectly
is far bigger than us it is far bigger
than technology it is more important
than
any of the products that any of us
produce today
and let's hope that if a century from
now people are not using iphones or
laptops or anything that we have today
journalism itself is still alive and
well
because our democracy depends on it
thank you smith i yield back the
gentleman yields back i now recognize
the ranking member of the full judiciary
committee mr
jordan from ohio for five minutes thank
you mr chairman i would slightly
disagree with the with the statement mr
smith
what what what our democracy depends on
is the first amendment
not necessarily journalism fine it's all
part of it as long as they're actually
adhering to the first amendment mr
travis in your at the end of your
statement you said i'm a first amendment
absolutist and i believe cancel culture
intertwined with identity politics
is the greatest threat to our country i
could not agree more do you have a
functioning first amendment when only
one side's allowed to talk do you have
free speech
when big tech big media and big
government decides what can be said and
what can be seen
no you don't not at all not at all and i
think that is the major
issue that our country is facing today
yeah more important than this this broad
concept of journalism which i'm all for
it's the
first amendment the right to speak and
to speak in a political nature and not
be censored
for speaking out in a political fashion
is that right yes sir
mr schabern said in his opening
statement that uh this bill would have
high quality professional journalism
would be able to form in this consortium
and cartel
uh is out kick high quality journalism i
would like to think so
some would disagree who who gets to
decide who defines what's high quality
journalism well i think that's one of
the big challenges
is determining what is and what is not
high quality journalism some of the most
high quality journalism
that we have seen over the years that
has been praised has ended up
not being true and that is why we need
such a robust
uh first amendment in general so that
our battles the marketplace of ideas is
not being artificially constrained which
is what i believe is happening now the
market's supposed to decide what isn't
defined what is high quality journalism
the first amendment decides that not
government is that right
i think that's correct yes sir you may
you you said something earlier too you
said
who fact checks the fact checkers who's
supposed to do that
it's it's fascinating my example
facebook has flagged
two different stories at outkick as
disinformation and destroyed our traffic
as a result
the first one was linking to the cdc
website
we appealed and said how can you make
this determination
the second one as i said was pretty
straightforward we linked to a wall
street journal editorial
from a high-end medical scientist
analyzing covid both of those were
flagged
we lost hundreds of thousands of dollars
in revenue because of facebook's
fact-checking decision
there was no appeals process they don't
even bother responding to us but in a
general sense mr travis
isn't it supposed to be the first
amendment that also fact checks the fact
that
more speech right yes number of
democrats have quoted justice brandeis
justice brandeis said
if there's quote misinformation or
disinformation out there the answer is
not to squelch that and stop that the
answer is to allow more speech to happen
i.e the first amendment correct that is
the entire theory of justice brandeis's
view of the first amendment and also
the entire basis of the marketplace of
ideas mr shadron do you think the london
times thought thomas paine was a high
quality journalist
i'm not sure i'm not sure i could answer
that i
i i'm not trying to respond to that uh
mr jordan i
you know what i what i can say is that i
represent
uh a vast array of points of view in my
membership
okay and uh every one of them has a
problem with the marketplace for their
uh content that they invest in uh
greatly
and it's not working i'm not saying
there's not a problem i'm all for using
any trust to go after the big tech
companies i'm all for doing 230
something we could do
right now we could repeal 230 take away
the liability protection we could do
that right now
if democrats want to do that we
certainly do we've introduced that
legislation
i'm all for doing that when i'm what i'm
nervous about is this alliance between
big government and big tech that mr
greenwald talked about
but i also want to go to mr greenwald
and talk about this other alliance which
i think is just as frightening
and that's the alliance between big tech
and big government
big tech and big government in uh in his
in your statement mr greenwald near the
end of it you said
a mere two months after parlor ascended
to the top of the charts members of
congress demanded that apple and google
remove parlor from their stores and ban
any further downloading of the app
we've seen a b we've seen maybe a better
example just a couple weeks ago mr
greenwald we saw
two democrats send a letter to a t
telling them to take certain networks
off their not be a carrier for certain
networks
i just want to read something to get
your reaction to this because
mr travis said earlier mr greenwald mr
travis said we would all be rightly
concerned if government was censoring
speech and not big tech
but frankly it's both big government
censoring speech too because we had two
members democrat members of congress
write
to at t and they said we want a specific
answer to this question
how many of your subscribers tuned in to
fox news news max 1 america news
on u-verse directv at t tv for each of
the four weeks preceding the november
3rd
2020 election please specify the number
of subscribers that turn tuned into each
channel
so basically tell us who your customers
are how many you have and what they were
watching
mr greenwald do you find that a little
creepy and frightening like i do
the time of the gentleman has expired
but the witness may answer the question
briefly
very briefly it goes to the heart of the
concern that i have which is i think
there's a huge mismatch between the
rhetoric that
is uh being offered to justify this bill
and what the bill does if the concern
is the failure of local newspapers then
give
them the power to negotiate collectively
but not big media which is so often
embedded in the same problems that this
committee is discussing
the time gentlemen isaac spidey yields
back i now recognize the gentleman from
maryland mr raskin for five minutes
mr sissolini thank you mr buck thank you
for your leadership on this legislation
uh mr chavern um in the district that i
represent we've lost
a ton of local newspapers in montgomery
county in frederick county and carroll
county
i remember when i got to annapolis as a
state senator
there were i think four reporters from
the washington post one covered the
state house one cover the state senate
one covered executive and one covered
the state courts today they've got one
reporter trying to cover
all of state government and that creates
a serious problem in terms of
transparency and integrity and
corruption
so this goes right to the heart of why
we have a first amendment in democracy
it's all about
self-government and making sure that
people understand what government is
doing
if we pass this legislation is there
actually hope of reviving local papers
or are we just trying to
arrest the erosion in the numbers of uh
journalistic entities that exist right
now
oh absolutely revive i mean what you're
seeing is
the audience for that product is bigger
than ever
the engagement with audiences is intense
again you're looking at an industry that
has many many more readers than it ever
did
in whatever the golden print era was but
the finances
are much much worse so there
and the reason why that is is the the
digital intermediaries
google and facebook in particular that
stand between us and our audience
take most of that value and that has to
be addressed
mr trevor um some of our colleagues have
been railing about what they call
cancel culture um i just made a quick
list off the top of my head of some
people
that right-wing conservatives have tried
to censure or
cancel privately publicly or defund or
boycott
here's some of them congresswoman liz
cheney who they tried to
uh kick off of her chairmanship of the
house republican conference senator bill
cassidy from louisiana
senator richard burr any of the 17
republican members of congress
who voted to impeach and convict donald
trump for inciting violent insurrection
against the union
abc acorn tv host samantha b
campbell soup to dixie chicks new york
times reporter sophan
deb comedian kathy griffin guinness
hallmark
cnn commentator mark lamont hill nike
pepsi
the new york times the words climate
change and science based and numerous
government agencies and documents
starbucks target and on and on and on
um so do you find that the cancel
culture
uh is limited to one side of the
political spectrum or do you think
there's a lot of right-wing council
culture out there which really
got this whole all the engines of
censorship
rev uh congressman i come at this
again representing the people creating
quality journalism
and the best answers for all of this is
to have the
most amount of good information good
journalism out there possible
and we currently have a system that
devalues that content
and and constrains our capacity to
uh to deliver good information and the
answer is a diversity
of of journalism thank you and finally
mr smith uh
it's fascinating that you're here
advancing the position you have um
first can you tell us how your
quasi-monopoly power today to negotiate
with isolated non-organized media public
media publishers
um gives you a bargaining advantage and
then
if we do pass this legislation do you
think this is a transitory
and transitional problem or do you think
it's systemic and structural and we're
going to
need to keep something like this going
forward indefinitely
well i would focus on two things first i
would focus frankly more on the needs of
the smaller publishers if you're a small
news organization if you're one of these
you know
still 1500 local county based
you
you
you
okay
you
you
this guy's a yeah